y llegó el momento de hablar de salud en
directo América por ello le doy la
bienvenida a mi compañera más Romero
sala Andrés mar empezamos hablando del
cáncer de garganta porque los casos
están en aumento en los últimos años sí
ha saltado la alerta en la comunidad
científica de este aumento de casos
tanto de garganta como orofaríngeo que
es el otro nombre el nombre técnico
digamos que tiene este este tipo de
dolencia el crecimiento por supuesto
será sobre todo en los países del Norte
global por el envejecimiento de la
población y por tener más detección que
no es el único ahora lo veremos el
principal factor de riesgo además es lo
que más sorprende porque ha cambiado y
es el sexo oral sin protección sobre
todo a raíz de los contagios de VPH el
virus del papiloma humano que se conoce
sobre todo por provocar cáncer de cuello
uterino pero que en este caso también
sucede es un virus además de transmisión
sexual como decíamos por eso uno de los
principales factores de riesgo es haber
tenido varias parejas sexuales sin
protección insistimos el problema no las
parejas sexuales sino que ese sexo sea
protegido o no más de seis parejas
sexuales orales a lo largo de la vida
tienen
cinco veces más probabilidad de
desarrollar en el futuro un cáncer de
garganta de hecho se prevé se sabe que
los contagios de VPH son bastante
comunes la mayoría de la población las
puede combatir con facilidad Pero hay
algunas personas que no y allí es cuando
entramos en una situación que puede
contener pues este riesgo a futuro sobre
todo se sabe como decíamos que la
principal el crecimiento de casos
suceden países del Norte global
occidentales sin embargo varias cifras
de la Organización Mundial de la Salud
indican que en la región de las Américas
también van a crecer en los próximos 20
años en las mujeres por ejemplo pasaba a
tener una incidencia del 4,1 en el 2020
hacer de 6 en el 2040 en los próximos 20
años y en los hombres por ejemplo pasa a
ser la incidencia es decir la cantidad
de casos de cáncer de garganta de 18,8
en 2020 hacer de 26 en 2040 por lo tanto
bueno vemos a que en el futuro puede ser
un problema mayor y tendremos estar
preparados Así es mar el virus del
papiloma humano tiene vacuna y cuéntenos
se podría usar para prevenir el cáncer
de garganta claro podría ser no es una
vacuna que está diseñada desde hace
bastante tiempo sobre todo pensada para
combatir el cáncer de cuello uterino que
se genera a través también del mismo
virus no del VPH sin embargo en ese caso
sabemos que es muy efectiva no sabemos
Qué tan efectiva es en los casos de
cáncer de garganta y un estudio
publicado en 2019 que muestra Cuántas
personas con presencia de VPH en la
garganta habían en un grupo de personas
vacunadas y en un grupo de personas sin
vacunar y arroja resultados mixtos por
ejemplo en los casos del VPH 16 que es
uno de los más comunes que provoca
cáncer vemos que hay mucho más presencia
de virus en las personas sin vacunar que
en las personas vacunadas Lo mismo
sucede con los VPH 31 33 etc pero por
ejemplo cuando medimos cualquier tipo de
VPH que genere que sea carcinogénico es
decir que pueda provocar cáncer el
porcentaje es exactamente mismo y lo
mismo sucede algo parecido cuando
medimos cualquier la presencia de
cualquier tipo de VPH la diferencia solo
de dos puntos porcentuales del 20,4 del
18,5 Por lo tanto falta más datos para
saber qué está pasando sin embargo sí es
cierto que hay muchos países que ya
están recomendando que se aplique esta
vacuna del bph no solo las chicas a las
mujeres adolescentes que es lo que se
solía hacer para prevenir cáncer uterino
sino a toda la población indistintamente
del género y un tema sobre el cual hay
mucha estigmatización todavía hoy en día
mar seguimos hablando de cáncer Pero
esta vez del cáncer de ovario porque hoy
es el Día Mundial contra esta enfermedad
sí Andrés el ocho de mayo se conmemora
la lucha contra esta enfermedad que
además es uno de los más letales para
las mujeres o para todas las personas
que tengan o varios solo en 2020
fallecieron más de 207.000 personas a
raíz del cáncer de ovario los
principales factores de riesgo entre
otros son haber tenido por ejemplo
familiares con este tipo de cáncer o
tener endometriosis entre otros aquí
traemos las cifras en el continente
americano de la mortalidad por cáncer de
cuello uterino y algunos de los países
con más mortalidad por ejemplo Uruguay
Colombia o México en la región aunque
también es importante destacar en el
Continente Canadá Jamaica Argentina o
Perú y en el lado de los que tienen en
menos mortalidad estaban por ejemplo
República Dominicana o Guatemala Qué
puede explicar estas diferencias entre
muchos factores porque sabemos que el
cáncer es difícil de saber con detalle
porque sucede Y por qué no pueden ser
por ejemplo simplemente factores de
detección de capacidad de detección de
cáncer entonces bueno Esta es la
situación más o menos en nuestro
continente ahora por qué este cáncer es
tan letal sí aprovechamos de este día
para explicarlo y también para poder
intentar ayudar a prevenirlo no hay
muchos factores que lo explican es el
más mortal de los cánceres ginecológicos
sabemos por ejemplo que menos del 40% de
los pacientes que son diagnosticados y
diagnosticadas con cáncer de ovario
llegan a curarse eso es un porcentaje
muy bajo es decir el 60% Nunca llegan a
curar ese cáncer y la tasa de
supervivencia cinco años es del 49% en
la mitad no sobreviven a los 5 años
desde su diagnóstico Por qué sucede
primero porque no hay una prueba de
detección temprana y precoz para este
tipo de cáncer se detecta Entonces
cuando ya aparecen síntomas y además los
síntomas son muy confusos Se pueden
confundir muy fácilmente con dolencias
menores es que los síntomas de los que
hablamos son por ejemplo dolor abdominal
o de espalda presión en el área de la
pelvis sangrado después de la menopausia
o ámbitos en los ámbitos en los cambios
en los hábitos de ir al baño por lo
tanto este tipo de síntomas como vemos
Se pueden confundir muy fácilmente con
cualquier otra cosa y cuando las
pacientes los empiezan a detectar y
llegan a las consultas médicas el cáncer
suele estar muy avanzado entonces bueno
en días como hoy son precisamente las
ocasiones las que debemos recordar e
intentar acudir a los médicos siempre
que veamos alguna normal alguna pues
cosas que no sean normales y también a
pedir más investigación científica para
tener detecciones más precoces de esta
dolencia Así es enfocarnos también en la
prevención mar Muchísimas gracias por
esta detallada explicación Gracias
Andrés